So this lesson was all about
relationships and filters and the measures that they facilitate.
We started by defining different relationship types,
also known as cardinality,
and the filtering directions of relationships,
which play an important role in how data is reflected in reports.
As you learned in this lesson,
the existence of a relationship doesn't do you any good unless the setup is correct,
and even though Power BI will try to recognize relationships on your behalf,
it's important to know relationships well enough to determine whether Power BI has
helped in the right way or if perhaps you need to make some corrections.
We also discussed filtering in
a reporting context and the different ways that filters can be applied,
layering on top of not only the filtering pane but
individual groupings in visuals, slicers, etc.
We went through implicit DAX and quick measures,
which are the simplest ways to get your calculations into your reporting context,
including basic such as some min-max and average on the implicit side,
and more advanced quick measures that are still
readily available for you to use as is out of the quick measure list.
Then we went through the two custom DAX functions that rely on filters the most,
which are SUMX and CALCULATE.
These are the Swiss Army knife-type custom DAX functions
that I lean on time and time again,
and that we use in conjunction with filters that we can add
into the calculations such as filter, all, and relationship.
We also touched a little bit on USERELATIONSHIP,
which you would use in a many-to-many context or in circumstances
where you might have to leverage an inactive relationship in your model.
At this stage, we've gone through building your data model,
making a report in the most basic of senses,
and creating some custom calculations,
so you're off to a great start.
Next lesson, we're going to learn how to build on this for those more unusual situations
where you need a little bit more of beyond-the-standard star schema.